all right Christian yes Christian
where'd you grow up where you from I'm
from the San Fernando Valley and tell me
about your family growing up
um well I was I was born with spom
menitis so I didn't supposed to
survive um I always tell people I was
born dead that was me so I told people
I'm a gift to to this world because I'm
still here and um
um my childhood was pretty it was all
right like as far as I can
um like remember the good things but um
when I was uh
five I was being um
mstic um
for my parents own selfish reasons you
know for they for her drugs her alcohol
whatever
it was for and I I just think more
because I look like my my father so I
think it's just more that she was more
angry that I look like him and the way
that he did her and treated her so I
think she just took it out on me too and
then the way that she was letting other
people get at you yeah like she was
letting me like she tell me let's go
play a game we're going to go play the
game all I know after the game I get ice
cream I get
dollars you know what I'm saying so I
was willing to play but didn't know what
they was doing was not what they
supposed to be doing to me cuz I was I
was a baby I was a
kid and
um it lasted until I was eight and then
I left with my
um my my mom's first cousin I went to
Alabama and I had an amazing time out
there I had a fun time and then when I
came back I was I think 11 when I came
back to cell and went back to my M my
granny and my mom's house and um my M my
my mom and my dad had this um they lived
in the
projects and um in bua they live in the
bua the projects in BMA and um when I
was
12 I was supposed to go I wanted to go
with my brother because they used to um
used to he used to like go into cars and
stuff like that but I wanted to go with
him because I was a tomboy I um was
developed at a young age you know what I
mean so I wanted to go with him but he
made me go home and um when I got home I
went to the kitchen give me some to
snack on my dad and his friends was at
the table playing dominoes and and stuff
like that getting
high and getting drunk I call my dad the
garbage disposal because he does any
kind of drugs like whatever gets him
high that's what he's going to do and I
went to my room did my homework and
stuff and then like
maybe 15 20 minutes after I finished my
homework my dad and his friends came in
there and they um raped me my dad took
my virginity they held me down and they
raped me it was five but I don't um call
it rape I call it that they [__] me
you know they [__] me they [__] me
so hard that it pushed my uterus back
like and my uterus is tilted like I
can't carry babies it's hard for me to
carry babies they eventually abort their
self and I had to get an abortion at a
young
age but um it was not a regular abortion
I had abortion with a clothes hanger and
that was the worstest pain I ever felt
in life like you had abortion what what
kind of with the clothes hang hanger a
clothes hanger yeah it was a house
abortion cuz I was too young to go to a
regular abortion clinic and I had ran
away from home so I couldn't um have my
mom and my dad do it because they was my
abusers you know what I mean so this
Mexican lady um took me to her house and
they she her and her sister gave me an
abortion with a clothes hanger and I
paid him 300 bucks you were how old
again I was 12 12 yeah and I stole that
money to um for my grandma so I'll be
able to get it done because I didn't
want to um have a baby and it reminded
me of what they did to me you know the
first time I ever turned a trick a date
was I was 13 you know I didn't know what
I was doing but I was
13 and it was this guy named sunny and
he was cool like after we finish
everything he let me take a shower and I
just I bleach my bleach my body
in his shower and I cried and um ever
since then I can't to bathe without
using bleach because I feel still feel
like I'm dirty so I scrub my skin like
literally until it turns red and I still
do it to today to this day it haven't
changed so um it's got to be very
difficult for you doing the kind of work
you do I really don't
um I date but I really don't date like I
used to like I didn't got stabbed in my
neck I didn't got cut in my neck right
here guy tried to cut me from here to
here because he didn't want to pay
me I didn't got stabbed in my back I
mean I didn't
um got punched I didn't got guns pulled
out on me
um it's just been hard it been a lot of
uh [__] [__] you know it was um it was
rough for me like I know how it feels to
have to real feel true pain to feel
broken to feel like you're empty and
it's nothing inside you you know um you
had neither parent on your side it seems
no and I was
uh it it made me
evil thank
you it made me evil
so I used to uh
I used to hurt people innocent people
you know that I'm not happy and I'm not
proud of but I you know I don't regret
it because it's it taught me a lot but
um I wanted them to feel my
pain and I didn't understand that they
couldn't uh feel what I feel because
everybody's hurt is different
everybody's pain is different
and I wanted people to feel it you know
I wanted people to feel the hurt and the
pain that I had inside like I felt like
it was no ending like I was locked in a
box and there's no [__] end to
it and now uh I have mental
problems I have a lot of you know
friends in my head you know and I've
been having them since I was 12 I used
to sleep under um you know the pant
tables that's in the park I used to
sleep under those for like a year and a
half and sunny and then um he let me
come and stay in his back
house and his wife was gone she was gone
for like a year or something in Europe
or wherever wherever she was you
know and he let me stay until she came
back you know and then when she came
back I had to go so he put me up in a
room for a while and he took care of me
he was good to me and they killed him
you know they killed him they robbed him
and killed him and they didn't have they
shouldn't have never done that to him
cuz he was an angel you know he was good
he was real good to me he was older man
and he was good to me he took care of me
real good I didn't have to want for
nothing I didn't have to ask for nothing
it was already done you
know was there was a sugar daddy type
relationship it was more of a friend he
was more of a friend because we didn't
have sex you didn't we only had sex one
time and then when he found out my my
real age he never um touch me sexually
how old were you at the time I was 13 13
so he never touched me like sexually
anymore he never asked for sex he never
did nothing he just took care of me you
know he made sure I didn't have nowhere
to go but um they killed him when I was
so he
just put up at the wrong time I guess
and they killed him these little gang
bangers killed him in
Hollywood
so you know that sucks cuz he would have
been a friend for life you
know
and what else when I was 16 so you you
were on your own yeah I was on my own
I've been on my own since I was 12 years
old I never been back home with my mom I
never moved back in her house I never um
moved in my back in my granny house did
you go to school huh did you go to high
school I went to school but I got my GD
when I went to prison for the first time
I went and got my GD and I got certified
in
welding I went to prison for assault
with a deadly weapon with bodily injury
with
Force because I drilled this dude in the
head with the drill we was fighting and
he was hitting me and I picked up
whatever I was at my reach my arm reach
and I drilled him I was
19 so that was my first time going to
prison and they um tried to give me life
for that but good thing he didn't die
so it got dropped down CU I end up
getting a paid lawyer from one of my
friends one of my little sugar daddies
art he paid for me a lawyer so they
dropped it down to start with a deli
weapon a body injury but that was not my
first time committing a violent crime my
first time in actionality committing a
violent crime I was
13 I set this dude on
fire same guy one of the guys that
molested me one of my father's friends I
set him on fire and I watched him burn
and I watched him scream and
um he wanted me to put them out but I
wouldn't put him out I just watched his
his flesh melt and it's really like to
smell a person a human flesh body burn
it it stinks and it stinks worse than a
dead fish that been you know in your
refrigerator for a week you know worse
than a dead rat but I watched them and
it made me feel
um it made me feel good like I enjoyed
it and it and and I don't know if it's
sick to say that but it I really enjoyed
watching him burn and that's when I fell
in love with fire so I learned about
fire and I learned what fire can do and
what you can do with fire how you can
make it dance how you can make it lift
off the off the concrete how you can
make it sit in your hand how you can set
your hand on fire without burning in it
like the difference between the F fires
the yellow the blues the Reds you know
how you can make it entwine and make it
look like it's pink and purple you know
um I uh really didn't
feel I say myself until I was like
16 and I met this older lady and she
um basically you know piece me up like a
puzzle she was 85 and she pieced me up
like she really really helped me because
if I never met her I would either be
dead or in jail for life or stuck in a
mental
hospital
y do you have kids I have a daughter you
did have a daughter yes how were you
able to have a daughter um my best
friend I call her my baby mama she um
had her for me oh I see cuz I can't have
I had a got pregnant with my son when I
was
and the doctor let him die she let him
suffocate in my stomach my paaca
ruptured and it detached from the wall
so she supposed to had gave me emergency
SE section but she didn't she let him um
suffocate and she let him
die and she told me she was a Korean
lady she told me I didn't deserve to be
a mother because of where I was at to to
had to come to the hospital cuz I had
got a violation I was on Parole and I
end up getting a violation so I was went
to CW and I was
pregnant and she told me I didn't
deserve to be a mother but you never
asked why I was in prison you never
asked why I'm here you never know what
happened for me to even be in here so
why would you judge me how can you tell
me that I'm not worth being a mom or not
worth having kids you know what I mean
how can you tell me that you know and
that was my last baby I ever I ever had
that was my last time ever getting
pregnant
um it's really hard for me to get
pregnant because my
liver sits in front of my uterus and my
uterus is tilted so I can't have babies
basically um did you raise your daughter
yes from from from day one when she had
her I was there you know I missed the
birth because I had to go bail my
husband out my ex-husband I had to go
bail him out of jail so um my niece my
peanut butter and jelly she was there
and she basically delivered my
baby yeah she had to have a csection so
she basically delivered her and
um I've been having her I never she
never left left me she um the social
workers
came um they took her and she was gone
for like 4 days she was a baby but they
get they bring her back they made her
give her they made them give her back to
me to me and my husband
um and she been with me she never never
been apart from
me she always been with me she's at home
right now my nephew um is taking care of
her because I'm going through a um a
case right now and so I gave him
temporary custody over her because I
don't want um just in case I have to go
do prison time or do some jail time that
he will have all authority to to take
care of her the way I need you know what
I'm saying to take her to the hospital
go pick her up from school you know and
stuff like that because right now I'm
once again fighting start with a daily
weapon um this guy named Kevin uh he
tried to force me to get in the car and
um I don't take that um
lightly like I promised myself I'll
never let nobody make me feel the way
that I feel when I was young and I
promis I would never let nobody take
anything from me again because that was
what's done to me it was toen a lot was
toen from me when I was little and I was
robbed from a lot of stuff so I promis I
would never let nobody do that again so
um I bust him in the head with a clipso
bottle yeah I knocked him in this air
with a Calypso bottle but he hit me
first you know so I don't know what to
say but they said I was more aggressive
than he was and I don't know how cuz I'm
a girl and he's a guy you know what I
mean but they said I was more aggressive
just like they said the first time I was
more
aggressive but you know you got to
protect yourself out here it's not it's
not easy it's not a game people think
it's fun and it's games being out here
prostituting or walking these streets
it's not fun
how long have you done it I've been
doing it since I was 13 I've been out
here since I was 13 years old you worked
with pimps hell no I never never had a
pimp and I never paid no man no I'm a
renegade as they say I keep all my money
my baby's my pimp my daughter that's who
pimps me cuz she gets all the money you
know are drugs a part of your life um I
smoke weed and I smoke cocaine sometimes
yeah not all the time but but I smoke it
it just relieves it just when I smoke
crack it just basically slows my mind
down a little bit cuz my mind stays
speeding like and if I didn't have it I
wouldn't be able to sleep that's how I
sleep that's how I really sleep cuz I
refuse to take meds I don't like the
pills I don't like meds I don't like to
feel like a zombie I don't like to feel
like I have no control over me so I
don't do anything that makes me feel out
of character or um me not feeling like I
am you
know hearing you speak about some of the
men that have been in your life it
sounds like you don't necessarily hate
men do I hate them it sounds like you
don't I used to you used to I used to
hate men I used to this is my ex-wife
tied on my chest right here um I used to
hate man I used to um I us want to hurt
them I used to think about all kind of
like sick [__] to do to them you know
because I felt like all man was [__]
off but my granny told me I can't judge
everybody as as the same and I can't
treat everybody or put them all in the
same category because they're not the
same everybody's different but um I
don't mess with men like that though I
prefer not to have sex with them I
prefer not to um give them head but I
have to do what I have to do for money
right sometimes so I got to live I got
to get it the way I live you know so but
I really don't date that much like I
have certain few guys that I would date
and mess with but I don't um have sex
with them you know we we pass that MH so
I usually like Jack them off or talk
nasty to them or you know give them one
of their like have one of their little
fantasies you know what I mean or I hook
them up with another girl or I'll watch
them sleep with another woman and I play
with my [__] you know or something like
that but um I really don't care for sex
like
that how how old are you now I'm 38
38 yeah you you have any regrets in your
[Music]
life
no honestly
no do you feel like if you had different
set of parents your life would have
looked very very different probably so
yeah I'll probably be the same see a lot
of people a lot of things that I done
been through and went through a lot of
people don't survive them things they a
lot of them commit suicide a lot of
people commit suicide and a lot of
people be angry for a long time but I
have to learn how to
um put that demon to rest because if I
didn't I would wouldn't be here now you
know I would never have my baby I would
never I would never learned anything I
would just been evil did you did you
forgive your parents of course you do
yes my mom I forgave her and I love my
Mom all I wanted to do was just you
know have her give me the love that she
gave to my sister you know she gave my
sister like hella love you she spoiled
her and she spoed her when she was older
and why why do you think you were
treated
differently because I guess I was like
my dad cuz you look like your
dad and she had to have somebody to take
it out on because her mom was her mom
was abusing her physically I mean not
physically but mentally because she used
to call her fat she used to tell her she
stink and I never knew you know that she
did that until one day I walked in um
walked to my I walked in my granny house
and she was telling my mom them hurtful
things you know and I told her my granny
like you supposed to be Christian you
say that this is his ler house why are
you um telling her that why are you even
talking to her like that so it gave me
some kind of insight of why my mom
you know down me you know cuz she had to
have somebody to take it out on
right so you only know what you learned
you only know what you taught or what
you experience in life that's all you
know you don't know anything else you
know you can't say oh I know how to do
this if you never done it or you never
tried to do it you know or you never
seen it done
so what do you go through emotionally
what what kind of things have you had to
deal with probably because of your
childhood I go through a lot of things
emotionally like my emotions are [__]
off they're like everywhere like it's
it's hard for me to
um it's hard for me to
love but when I
do I love
hard and I love real hard so when a
person [__] me by me giving you know me
letting them in it hurts you know what I
mean and I want to hurt him for doing
that but
um I just leave him
alone like I don't know like everywhere
it seemed like every little place I go
like women don't like me period I'm
going just tell you the honest God truth
like it doesn't matter where I go they
don't like
me they talk about me they put jackets
on me they lie on me they tell fibs on
me I mean I'm not the baddest [__] out
there but to me I am but I'm not the
baddest [__] out there they have some
females out there that's bad you know
what I'm saying and I'm like why are you
hating on me but I have to come to terms
is a lot of women don't like because I
am strong minded I have a lot of
confidence I don't hide my scars I don't
hide my flaws I got this for my son you
know um I went up to 245 lbs with him
and I was like 135 140 when I started
when I got pregnant but um I don't hide
my flaws I don't hide my scars I I
embrace them you know what I mean it's a
part of my life and it's a part of my
story that um that tells a story every
scar on my body tells a story like what
I've been through and what have been
done to me you know I've been tortured
like really literally tortured sexually
physically mentally you know emotionally
I've been tortured you know uh um not
just by my mom not just by my dad but by
people you know and women you try to be
nice to them you try to look out for
them because I know how it is out there
being in the streets but they're messy
and they like to tell lies and they like
to [__] make you look bad to make
themsel look good but you wondering why
these men are these people want to come
and [__] with me or see what's up with
me because of what you're saying they
want to know why are you saying this
about me so you making me more
interested than you you making yourself
and you don't even know it you know what
I mean I'm a Pisces I'm a I'm a lover
I'm not a fighter but if I have to go
there I will go but I know if I go I
have to go all the way because I have
too much to lose I have two strikes you
know this this case right here that I'm
I'm fighting right now it can strike me
out because it's violent my whole record
is violence no prostitution it's no
drugs I've never been arrested for
prostitution I've never been arrested
for drugs it's all violent and it's
again man except for one it's against a
woman I hit her with a 2x4 in her knees
I made her fall cuz she was a big ass
[__] she was like she looked like she
was like 6'5 and she was big and I'm
short so I had to break her down to my
side so I hit her with a 2x4 on her
knees so she got like a permanent Mark
of board on her knees right now yeah and
I went to jail for that and they tried
to offer me 14 years but the girl never
showed up so they had to drop it yeah
but this case right here the guy is
coming to court and he's trying to press
it you know but and trying to act like
he's really really the victim but I have
in my phone videos of me my niece my
other niece at his house partying you
know what I mean like kicking it having
fun partying and [__] like that so he's
more of a thing cuz he mad cuz he can't
get
sex and I wouldn't sleep with him
because he probably got AIDS you know
what I mean he probably got HIV look who
he messed with I didn't seen to mess
with some of these women that I know for
sure have some some type of disease you
know what I'm saying some type of
something you know like they're the
walking [__] dead you know and I
can't do it I love myself too much
that's why I had to slow down on you
know prostitution and stuff like that
and a lot of these men don't want to use
condoms because a lot of these wom women
doesn't use protection with them and
that's
nasty just to have different 10
different dicks you without protection
that's disgusting to me so I just have
to slow down you know what would you say
is your greatest strength my greatest
strength is my
mind yep my mind because no matter what
I've been through I always um always
have a good heart I stay I stay the same
I don't
change and even though I've been through
[__] my heart is golden I'll give a
person a shirt off my back I help people
I don't um turn my back on nobody I help
them even if they [__] me I still help
them you know just to show them it's
still good people out here and no matter
what you do it don't fade me because
this doesn't mean anything to me a lot
of people cherish and um love money and
they cherish it and I does I don't
cherish money or materialistic things it
doesn't mean nothing to me because I
can't take it when I go you know what
means means something to me is my
happiness my daughter's happiness my
daughter's safety her life I want to be
here to see
her grow up I want to see be here to see
her go to her prom I want to be there to
make her prom bomb you know go with her
to buy her dress you know do her little
prom her little party you know stuff I
want to see her walk down the aisle I
want to be here for that and the only
how I'm going be here for that if I if I
slow down you know so I had to slow down
I had to compress my anger my temper
because if I didn't I would really I
wouldn't be here how do how do you keep
a a good heart a loving heart after
everything you've been
through
God I keep him first I used to be angry
at with him I used to be really really
angry with him and
um like I said the lady this older lady
she
um she showed me something different
because it's not God who make the people
do what they do is the people that have
a sick mind and they make the choice to
do what they do cuz God gave us choice
you know he didn't tell my mom to do
what she did he didn't tell my dad to do
what he did you know they did it by
choice by their own living choice and
people always say [__] love [__] this
but you can't say [__] love because it's
not the love that's hurting you cuz love
don't hurt it's the people that you love
that hurt you and if they hurt you that
mean they never love you in the first
place because it hurting
you you know and to me love is like it's
like the air you breathe you can't see
it you can't touch it but you can feel
it
so if you feel that way with somebody
you're good but if they don't if they
hurt you They Don't Love You Because
love don't hurt and always people always
say [__] love love this and love that no
it's not the love it's the people it's
their choice they just either with you
for what they can get or what you can do
for them are just with you because they
know they can control
you you know a lot of people in this
world don't really want to be with
nobody really don't give a damn you know
they really don't give a [__] about
anything and I don't really trust nobody
because I feel if my mom and dad would
hurt me what the [__] would you do to me
you know what I mean you would damage me
way worter than they would you know what
I'm saying because them are my blood and
you're not [__] so I don't I know I
don't mean [__] to you so I know you
will hurt me so I really don't um I try
to keep my um I keep my circle small
it's not too many people that's inside
my circle you know what I mean cuz
people got big mouths they snitch they
tell everything you know what I mean and
um that they're scals they steal they do
all kind of little petty [__] that don't
even need to be done all you have to do
is just be you and you'll have what you
need you know and why would you steal
from me I will give it to you but they
do it anyways
right so it's hard but hey it's
life you know what I mean I've been
through the RoR scales the scales but I
made it I'm still standing I'm still
here all these scars I got on my body my
back all the scars I got on my back
that's the worst place that I'm scarred
up is my
back it look like somebody just took
this their little Scissor Hands and just
scraped me and then poke my back and all
kind of [__] but hey it's a part of my
life what would you say is the most
important lesson you've learned in your
life the most important lesson I
learned
is don't take things for
granted and don't underestimate no
one that's what I learned all right
Christian thank you so much for sharing
your story you're welcome wish you lots
of luck out here thank you thank
you